welcome back to new rock stars you dang
whippersnappers technology Kevin feige
is canonically technology as of the
finale of She-Hulk attorney at law on
Disney plus now you use out there may
think that having an electronic feige
connected to all the 5G in the air for
your convenience is hip and cool and
filled with the drip but I'm here today
to inform you that this now puts the MCU
in danger because what if I told you
that Kevin 5G is about to be hacked for
the glory of Hydra this is Rogue Theory
the show away pitch the wildest series
for the nerdy titles that we love my
name is Mt and growing wrong with me
today is a woman more Rogue than Rogue
from the X-Men it's Jessica Clemens
what's going on hi Jessica Clemens major
Jubilee fan right here number one
Jubilee fan yes she is the number one
Jubilee fan do not let Jessica tell you
any different at any other time than
this time she's telling the truth right
now why do you hate Jubilee so
um
is um
she's cool and she's the best X-Men the
most powerful and my goodness could it
be Dolph mine eyes deceive me why it's
Dom toretto's long-lost little sister
Whitney
yeah and I've got beef with the rock
baby and that's why the black Adam's
coming out today because we're having a
fight later and it's good yo that is the
weirdest beef in Hollywood I'll never
get over it kind of open their friends
because it sure is new chapters every
every new uh every now and then and
finally we have Peter Parker's new guy
in the chair because he forgot everybody
everyone forgot him I mean it's Eddie
thanks I feel so much better about
coming back oh man
I mean I just I just have to say
I'm team rock on that uh F9 kind of
stuff going on so yeah
come on I'm absolutely not what is it
between your team and team and Tyrese
Gibson no not Tyrese Gibson wasn't it no
no it's it's between him and uh Vin
Diesel Vin Diesel in our fight I love
Vin Diesel
I also love Vin Diesel see I'm not I
don't choose sides I just love I love
both of my bald-headed babies
sometimes that's just how family Works
family bites sometimes sometimes all the
time they just need to go to some family
counseling they'll get into it and then
afterwards they'll have a family potluck
or a family Barbecue exactly
just like the end of She-Hulk that was
basically just the ending of The Fast
and the Furious this brings us to our
first topic of today The Shield finale
speaking of The Shield finale
um other than the amazing Fast and
Furious uh cookout that we got the most
crazy thing from that episode was of
course the Revelation that Kevin feige
was indeed a robot the entire time in
the MCU and he makes the MCU narrative
in his robot brain however this presents
a massive massive problem because I
believe this is the first topic of today
that Zola inside of the Ultron Infinity
Body will take over the Kevin
installation robot and to be able to
transform the narrative
completely giving him ultimate power I'm
already giving us this is a piece of
data
we don't even need to explain but go on
I love this already I'm very into it
because we know like from um what if we
know that um the Zola Zola took over the
Ultron Infinity Body and now he is
locked in eternal battle with killmonger
um who try to take the Infinity Stones
for himself
um so I believe that uh this there was a
possibility that they exit that prison
and Ultron Infinity
um Zola Infinity takes on the goals of
the original Ultron he's like you know
what let me just keep ascending Higher
and Higher and Higher and try to become
the ultimate being in all of Marvel
which is Kevin
um so who is also a robot
so we could be seeing Zola a Zola MCU
the M the Z zcu the mzu I don't know
marvel Zola Universe the makuzu
that sounds like a show on PBS mckoozie
right after Caillou
oh my God Caillou is the most annoying
being on the planet uh but anyway uh
what do you guys think of this of this
theory of uh Zola taking over I I like
it I like the idea because I mean with
everything else that's been coming out
in terms of movie news and so forth I
mean if you think about it King the
Conqueror is about to take on
killmonger in a whole nother movie
Universe where they're gonna be boxing
about and let's be honest Kang looks
ripped I mean that trailer I was like
you ripped too but I don't know about
this one I don't know about this one
we're going from last black man in San
Francisco to this and they are too tall
it is no no the thing is it's me and my
mom were on the phone about this for two
hours yesterday he's always had that
body it's just always been hidden really
it's always been hidden even in
Lovecraft country was always but it was
like when he pulled up in those white
tight shirts I was like I was like
SpongeBob when he licks the he's licking
the eyes like I want to lick his stomach
me and my mom are like watching the
paparazzi and we're like yes look at
these images of our man like it's it's
keep going keep going though sorry he
he's I mean I have to admit he is a
man's man I mean the way he looks the
way it's just like sculpted and the way
his form is just boom boom like
seriously sounds like Eddie's warm first
form baby and we love to see
we support
them I'm like that man is fine nah man
get get warm for that form I ain't
stopping you yeah he is a handsome dude
like he is literally a work of art quite
literally so you got you got Kang and
you got killmonger they're about to
fight and then as they're fighting it's
gonna weaken what's his uh killmonger in
the whole little bubble uh ultron's
gonna get out he's gonna do his thing
he's gonna find a way to break the
fourth wall because he already knows how
to break through Dimensions I I feel
like there's so much credibility to your
to your theory honestly even if it's
going so Rogue as to involving other
movie cinema Universe cinematic
universes I feel like this is completely
something plausible so let's just look
at it get released and he's gonna be
like um I'm blinded by all of the
absolves no
no the first thing that Zola does in his
cabin robot bodies go see Creed 3 he's
like obviously beautiful beautiful now
back to ruining the MCU
not Kevin feige but Zola as Kevin Zola's
whole thing is that he just he just
envies the bodies of Jonathan majors and
we'll be Jordan so much he's racist so
he's just like I don't want to win
business I think black men are sexy I
don't want to admit it
oh man yeah I'm kind of like Is it wise
to have a Nazi possess the body of the
head of Disney but then I'm like well I
guess it wouldn't be the first time oh
the head of Disney Nazi
that's crazy
got him jumping on a dead guy Walt
Disney think about Disney hey there you
go it's a whoosh but no like I just
think that like this opens a lot of like
really unique opportunities for like
let's say like the Zola ticket takes
over Kevin feige what does that mean for
like our universe or like the copy of
our universe in the MCU like like do we
I would love to see like elements of our
reality
like be involved in a huge conflict like
all right now like you know like Zola is
in real life you know LA or like real
life in New York and like you know like
gwenpool or like real life like the
superheroes have to interact with our
real life and like maybe the Fantastic
Four they're already setting the stage
for
making a statement that bringing in
Deadpool doesn't mean that's gonna be
the beginning of breaking the fourth
wall She-Hulk the series has already
done that they've already stated we are
gonna have characters who are going to
break that fourth wall and if somebody
like you know Jennifer Walters is able
to do that then that kind of opens the
door for so many other characters to
Traverse into that not to mention we're
getting conversations of other
dimensions we're getting conversations
about the universes we're getting
conversations of all these different
things not to mention Quantum Mania
that's going to be coming about it's
going to reset a lot of timelines
there is nothing off the table that is
capable of utilizing that whole
perspective of breaking the fourth wall
coming in these movies to come and I I
I'm really believing that they're going
to try to make it as general of an
opportunity for everybody so that when
Deadpool comes it's not the only thing
people are going to be waiting for for
him to do oh he's gonna break the fourth
wall he's going to do this because I
mean obviously with that we get
opportunities where like Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe it goes Super meta
if they're already setting the stage for
meta humor then we know that this is a
very likely possibility and it's
something that has already been kind of
paved the way with She-Hulk and like you
know I feel like with the animation
medium
um of what if like you can just have
that story be part of the what if series
and be like hey uh what if freaking
Ultron I mean Zola Ultron won and like
he's literally takes over Kevin and
because like Kevin could easily be
adapted with animation be like all right
here's Kevin again
um
he's back and now um he's the new
Infinity Gauntlet that everyone wants I
don't know I feel like it'd be really
cool to involve him in season two plus I
mean Kevin feige definitely wants to be
in the MCU himself I mean he's already
made his entire world about it why not
be in it himself too honestly like I was
really hoping to see a physical Kevin
feige in that finale like when they said
Kevin I wanted a real one in fact I
think it's lazy that he
like come on Kevin get a job what were
you busy with seriously you're just
planning the next three phases of Marvel
come on
a minute to do a little Cameo I would
really have really enjoyed just like a
really candid conversation between Jen
and Kevin just like in a room just being
like hey you can't do this or like just
looking through his files and like I
would love to like to see like her
expose his X-Men plans like on a piece
of paper like hey look here it is
I almost was hoping to have kind of like
The Wizard of Oz thing where he's
actually behind the curtain like moving
levers and stuff like it's like just
you're not supposed to see this this
isn't part of the CG and then he closes
I'm sure she wrote something like that
but it just no Kevin feige was probably
like no we're not gonna do that he
turned down a lot of things he was the
reason why she ended up just having to
use a robot which is interesting because
he was the one that chose to go to the
writer's room so
um
hmm yeah show off the writers but not
yourself little [ __ ] oh my God little
[ __ ] but no uh okay so how do you think
the MCU would change if Zola was in
charge like what do you think Zola would
do to The Avengers like for example
Nazis he's a Nazi
thing
what else is here
he'd keep
literally majority of the Thunderbolts
except for the two yeah thank you
everybody but the two and then be fine
with the res you be like I actually
really like us agent he's a really good
guy uh he's a pretty good guy
the same pseudo kind of what we see and
what if where they're trapped in the
that orb that doctor strange has made or
whatever but maybe he gets out or
something I don't know I just think
it'll be more along the lines of like
I'm gonna blow up the moon like I want
him to be as like cartoony as Modoc I am
gonna blow up here I go
um and then the moon will be and then
like Saturn will be for the Nazis uh and
then we'll make another civilization
Despicable Me yeah they'll be Despicable
Me but like only racist style but yeah I
just think you probably put himself back
into the narrative as much as he was
back in the day less about any of the
newer villains because I guess the older
MCU was all like these are tangible
people that are you can touch whereas
now it's like this is a God here's a
demon monster King here is a guy with
the flaming skull so it's like those
people are unintouchable so you probably
like we're gonna go back to the
touchables it's like The Expendables
we're gonna go back to the Expendables
is such a sketchy term right it sure is
the name of my website uh it's a very
good website that does very legal good
things they're the touchables and The
Untouchables in this world anyway I
wasn't gonna say oh no it was a stupid
joke never mind uh this is what Joe you
guys ready for it
um
um what's it called if Zola was in
charge because he's racist uh he
probably changed the name of the New
Black Panther movie to wakanda for never
because he doesn't like the ground he's
like he's like that guy can stay and
it's Everett Ross he's like that guy can
stand yeah it's just it's this is like
ever Ross can absolutely be in the
sequel he's the only one that guy and
the whales and that is it that is
actually Ryan Gosling the New Black
Panther
oh my god let's bring this train to the
station this theory of Zola taking it
over
um the Kevin installation at Marvel
Studios HQ what do you guys think of
this is it rogus is it bogus is it
August I think it's it's definitely I'll
go ahead Eddie what's going on here
what's going on here Eddie what's going
on
yeah okay well Eddie leaves I'll go on
to say Mary Kate Jesus Christ
and I stick to what I say I'm not an
oath breaker like half the people in
House of the Dragon I said it was a
rocus at the beginning and it stays a
rogue fighting words yeah I'm gonna be
the one that's hung up in the courtyard
but you know whatever not
I agree I definitely feel like this is a
rogus theory I mean it's definitely got
plausible you know factors in it we've
already seen some of the road already
paid for us
um and plus I mean how much fun would it
be it looks like Marvel's really taking
a swing and just having fun with a lot
of their properties with you know in
terms of breaking the fourth wall and
doing a lot of fun stuff
um I feel like a lot more you know
characters are going to be seen in this
way they're going to be given
opportunities like this so it definitely
Rogues to me and I can't wait for that
episode I think that's an episode of
what if for sure like I think that
genuinely would be such a good pitch for
what if and unfortunately now anyone on
the internet can steal it once this
comes out Mt copyrighted do something
read this honestly if Kevin feige wants
to just take the idea go for it I would
love to be in the credits though all of
us all of us but what do you think
Whitney uh I also think that this is a
rogus and Kevin if you steal this idea
you owe each of us a cool Grand
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if that's on the table
episode where they're like I'll do
anything for bread and he was like well
what about food and he was like well
I'll watch a kid if I could have more
food we're like betting for Kevin feige
who's Never Gonna Kiss us Jonathan
Majors we might get maybe don't say
anything don't you ever put that curse
on me baby
look here Kevin Parker you can't be your
dad as he goes to sleep yes daddy Kevin
please kiss me to sleep he is my dad all
right I'm manifesting sweet forehead
kiss exactly and then that's all I want
and then I'm like I'm acting like I'm
asleep and then I go kiss me fat boy I
like it and then I make out with it
Jess has a really interesting feeling
that we cannot wait to hear about but
first be sure to head on over to new
rockstars merch.com wherever there is
still time to grab our latest Obsession
shirts Lady Justice inspired by the
She-Hulk series and our Ash and ruined
shirt inspired by house of the Dragon
these limited edition shirts won't be
available much longer so check them out
along with some of our other merch
options over at New rockstarsmerch.com
and we also want to thank Audible for
sponsoring this podcast because listen
to the new audible original the Sandman
act 3 the next installment of the number
one New York Times audio bestseller
based on the best-selling DC graphic
novels written by Neil Gaiman adapted
and directed by the award-winning audio
Master Dirk mags James McAvoy returns in
the title role of Morpheus Lord of
Dreams the Sailor cast features Kat
Dennings Christian Shaw Jeffrey Wright
reggae John Page and Neil Gaiman new to
act 3 are David Harewood KJ APA and Will
Wheaton in act three we follow Morpheus
on a grand journey to take care of
family business he visits with his son
Orpheus an act that comes with profound
consequences accompanied by delirium he
tracks down their estranged brother
destruction the only member of the
Endless ever to abandon their post and
in the end by seeking destruction
Morpheus just might bring those forces
upon himself act free of the Sandman
audio epic takes us through the fan
favorite collected volumes 8 brief lives
and the reality storm Tales of Volume 7
World's End a fully immersive listening
experience presented for the first time
in breathtaking 3D audio so go deeper
into the dreaming listen now only on
Audible we also want to thank wandery
for sponsoring this video go deeper to
the canals of numenor in the minds of
kazadum and more with the official Lord
of the Rings rings of power podcast host
Felicia Day and several special guests
provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunners JD Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs that you won't
want to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official V Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast ads for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app right now today all right gang
this leads us to our second topic of
today presented by the wonderful Jessica
Clemens take it away yes
um I'll keep mine under five minutes
um so I okay my theory is that um in the
my theory is that in the newer blade
movie we're gonna be kind of mimicking
what we saw in the very first blade
movie where it's gonna be them releasing
a demon that has to be put back in Hell
or anything in some underworld or some
fashion got to be put away and I think
it's gonna be chathon or cathode however
you guys like to pronounce it
um I think he's gonna be wrong
every video I've ever had people correct
me and I swear I've like taken their
notes and said it the way that people
correct me that time and then when I do
that they tell me no it's this way now
and I'm like you guys can't please
everybody
I can't make you happy I think cathode
is gonna be released in the blade movie
I think Shonda Rhimes is going to be
released in the blade movie uh and I
think I think they're gonna come out
when so there's different versions of
Blade there's been a bunch of there's
been comic books anime series uh the
animation uh anything there's a lot of
different versions of Blade but there is
a version of Blade that was a series
that didn't go past really the pilot
series uh didn't do that well and it was
blade House of cathode and I think
though that's not close to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think they're still
gonna listen to the movie and in the
movie The First blade movie they were
the house of a Rebus that is the
follower of like an Egyptian or the god
of like just shadows and darkness and so
I think there's different houses that
represent different magical beings that
are like all powerful or from the
beginning of time and so there is
clearly a house of cathode so I think
people are going to release c'thon and
he's gonna be like what the hell
happened to wonder Gore what the hell
happened to all my [ __ ] and he's gonna
stir [ __ ] Ruckus and Blake can't
fight him on his own so he's gonna have
to team up and I think he'll team up
with Dracula and I'll think he'll team
up with saracen who is on She-Hulk and I
think he'll team up with a bunch of
spooky characters that we've already
seen in the MCU and maybe we'll get new
ones but I think by the time Blake comes
to 2024 if we do get our Sasha Baron
Cohen as Mephisto he is also someone
they're gonna have to team up with and I
don't think it's a team up as in like
this is a good team up it's a team up as
in like how we saw and what if with
killmonger and Zola and all of them it's
like we don't want to be a team up we
all hate each other but we we have to
put this demon god back into where he's
from so I think him I think it's gonna
be this team going against cathode and
the The Souls of the Damned and trying
to put him back and wherever he is from
in the MCU now okay I a hundred and
million 10 degree and I just did a video
on this with a very similar Theory no
it's great no I agree with you it's
great uh because my it's mine's a little
tiny bit different mine is that I think
that the reason why
saracen was like I lost all my Powers I
can go in the light now it's so weird I
think that when the dark hole got
destroyed at Mount wundergore it like
destroyed because you know how all of
like the dark creatures draw their
powers from the dark hold
um I think that it Zapped like the
powers of the vampires and that's why
like saracen can go outside in the
daylight now and I think that him and
blade are gonna have to try to get their
powers back but cathon is gonna get
released
try to send him back to the demons so
that's like that's like how they get
into that fight in my eyes I really like
that like the the vampire powers being
connected to the dark hole that'd be
really dope yeah yeah because they are
they're just gonna they're gonna be like
wait what the hell happened in the dark
hole what happened to wonder Gore what
happened all my [ __ ] like that's exactly
I think what's going on so I have a
billion percent agree with Jess I agree
I feel like it'd be so great to see
first off a blade movie
uh to see you know because obviously
with the events of Multiverse of Madness
you know there's this ambiguous thought
as to how the actual ending happened
with Wanda and blah blah you know and of
course with Wonder Gore so seeing kathon
cathon shathon
he comes about I feel like that would be
a really great segue into incorporating
a lot more of the supernatural side
obviously with blade plus it would
obviously give us a great opportunity
for Marvel to bring in that big lovable
Thug uh man thing into The Fray and have
him be a part of it Ted exactly and have
him part of that as like part of this
the Deep natural magic of the world is
all this is that like just to have that
as a part of it too since we got him in
you know uh werewolf by night I just
would love to see him come back and I
think this would be a great opportunity
for that so I am all for this yeah I'm
all here for this TED Talk
a nugget of Insider knowledge is that on
slack we all everybody in the office
change their names for Halloween and Mt
is just man thing
now because I don't think you should
ever change it back I don't think you
ever should there you go that's my
spooky holiday babe
no I really like this idea of chathon
coming back because like that tease in
Multiverse of Madness was definitely
like here's chathon he's Canon and he's
actually a big deal in the MCU so he'll
be coming back later and I definitely
feel like um there is some type of
chathon threat on the horizon in the MCU
so I I just feel like you know him
coming back and a bunch of dark Forces
of the MCU just wanting to take him down
just because like he threatens the
hierarchy of like the maybe like the
demons and the dark parts of the the
universe so it's just like all right
Unholy Alliance let's just get this
thing going like you get your freaking
your hellstroms your Damon hellstroms
and your freaking satanishes and like
your daughter of Satan I forget the
daughter of Satan's name I forget her
name satanic
no satana us like Satan Satan Anna I
don't know Satan
Anna and Satan smushed together
um so I I definitely would I like this
idea of a dark Alliance forming that
let's just very like begrudgingly like
all right let's just take down your Thon
even though he's gonna kick our asses
probably but like you know let's just do
this
um but you know I like this Theory a lot
but so yeah I guess let's all vote on it
like Rogue is focused I think we all are
pretty much
Natalia Jess I hard agree I'm so glad
that we like have the same Theory though
that makes me feel cool
are you kidding me all three of you guys
like I would not expect nothing less you
guys are smart and me and Mt are smart
because we agree with you that's what
I'm saying
exactly we're taking your lead
but amazing Theory Jess we love this one
yeah it's great Jessica I love this so
much but now it is time for our Rogue
question you guys ready for this so
ready here we go ready because the Black
Adam man has dropped in theaters this
weekend but at this time that we are
recording this nobody has really seen
the film yet so let's get Rogue and have
some fun here and so give me your Rogue
spoiler for Black Adam having not seen
it yet okay I think that uh you know how
like like with Shazam he has to like
call out my name and it's like Shazam
you know uh I think that Black Adam is
gonna have the same thing but because
it's dtrj he's gonna have to call out
Jumanji yeah like at some point to
activate his powers he's just gonna be
like
like the exact ending of that movie and
it's gonna be like Shazam but better
yup that would be a crazy twist if like
Black Adam was he's like oh my God I
forgot that I'm Ian and I'm also a video
game character weird that's based on a
board game from the 1980s oh my God
that's hilarious I love that one Jumanji
Black Adam what what about you Jess I
think
um all hell's gonna break loose and
everyone's like oh no what are we gonna
do black Adam's not actually that
helpful or we didn't know that he was
gonna not actually help us that much I'm
basing this off of that Black Adam just
got unfrozen you guys and so he's
showing up and people are like help us
and he's like I don't know how to help
people I can barely walk I got atrophy
um so I think when that stuff happens
they're gonna look into the sky and
they're gonna be like oh it's Superman
he's here to help us and it lands on the
ground and is actually Shazam and
shazam's gonna be like we have the same
powers do you also have the same friends
and shazam's gonna be like do you want
to play Jumanji there you go you want to
play Jumanji together it's like yes of
course you want to watch this great
movie that came out with the rock and
Jack Black and he's like who's the rock
he's handsome I bet he's got a great
line of tequila too
um I feel like the way it's gonna end is
we're gonna get this scene where uh it's
just Black Adam by himself and then we
see this portal opening up and this
bright light shines and all of a sudden
sudden these two figures come out of the
out of the portal and you just see their
Silhouettes and when the light finally
dims it's actually Stephen Amell as
Green Arrow and Grant Gustin as The
Flash and he's like hey we need your
help come to our universe and then we
get a little stint of a couple episodes
of uh Black Adam in the CW whoa
DW Black Adam I don't know
if you are fine Dwayne is hilarious that
would be so funny but hey Dwayne Dwayne
gets monies like Dwayne I feel like
would be down for it he's just really
chill franchise Viagra baby
going
franchise Bluetooth comic book Bluetooth
I was just gonna say blue too blue shoe
for the DCU there you go yo Bluetooth
should pay the rock to change his name
to The Chew The Chew
it's like q b c f t d c e u
H there you go that's that's a mouthful
super easy to say but yeah
but that was the one to Whitney for
Jumanji one because like thank you I
like a good job reference
you guys are all amazing people yeah I
love going rogue with each and every one
of you thank you to all of you for
joining me on this episode and of course
to our amazing guest Jessica Clemens
what an event lending him and any
Villanueva support our Channel by
checking out all of our awesome merch
over at rockstarsmerch.com and of course
head on over to Eddie's podcast uh the
film Lucifer's podcast
um he does some really great stuff over
there so uh check that out too you can
share some of our your own Rogue
theories on our Discord if you're over
18 check the link for the new rockstars
Discord server in the description and
join the conversation today you can
follow me at masterton if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] you can
follow new rockstars on all social
platforms and be sure to subscribe to
our channel here on YouTube we love you
guys so much thank you guys for spending
time with us and we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
foreign
[Music]